hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe that
hungry entrepreneurs deserve help and so
today I'm going to be talking about
Evernote for my Android Evernote is one
of my favorite apps I use it on my
Android device all the time I'm using a
note 2 from Samsung at the moment and
wanted to share with you a few ways that
I use it and hopefully give you some
ideas on how you can use it as well so
the first thing that I find really
helpful is to on the sorting to figure
out if you want to sort by notes or by
notebooks and so turn it back on here if
you sort my notes what's going to happen
this is usually the default view is it's
going to show you the most recent notes
that you've updated this is going to be
across all your different notebooks you
can see that today I updated my workout
sheet yesterday updated my to market
media note business ideas radio show
other things that I've done so it's your
most recent notes are shown at the top
so I have three thousand eight hundred
and eighty-eight notes here there are 86
notes here and it's going to show me my
most recent ones all the way down to the
least recent ones so sometimes this is
really helpful if you are just editing
your most recent notes where it's not
helpful is if you're working on a
notebook and you want to gain access to
all your different notes in that
specific notebook then this isn't as
helpful because know for example
workbooks is going to be one of my
personal ones these are business ones
this is a travel one that I just went to
New York from so this is kind of all
over the place is only sorting by the
most recent if you want to sort by
notebooks you can just press dock here
and go notebooks and now you can see all
the different notebooks that I have my
book business notes personal tds is a
salsa company I'm involved in receipts
family receipts so this is how to gain
access to it and if I click on any of
them click business notes for example
it's still going to show me in order of
the most recently updated one but again
this is only now related to my business
notes so in terms of how I organize I
love Evernote again because all of the
stuff they update here on my phone is
also automatically shown on my computer
and my mobile devices wherever I am it's
automatically updated so in terms of how
I structure it I have important ones
that I really want to see at the top
with these
stars star always at the top I have
business notes personal notes again this
is a salsa company that I'm an investor
an owner in I have my receipts I have my
family receipts within all of these I
have categories so within my business
receipts it'll be by by quarter so
quarter one quarter two and I have those
all sorted you can see how I kind of
sort my stuff here I have agreements as
a signed contracts business cards that I
keep track of accountant government
stuff tax tough family receipts memories
recipes places a check out in Toronto
I'm from Toronto if I read a blog post
about interesting place I want to go to
I can put it in here just to show you as
an example there's a new board game play
so I want to check out there's some good
ramen places board game cafes there's a
saltwater pool different restaurants so
wherever I see someplace that I want to
check out I'll record it here and then I
have it automatically across all my
devices vacation notes where whenever
I'm going on a different place so for
example I've got a Europe cruise coming
up I'll make notes of where we're going
to be what's in each place so if I'm
going to Rome it'll show up on here
there's this is how to get Rome
transportation so we don't land in the
city we land outside and this is how to
get there so I have that information
accessible and then well this room note
is empty so I haven't updated that yet
but basically for every place I go to I
have my notes and then I can just load
it up and I have access to everything so
this is parma de Majorca where the
places were stopping out I just go to
cruise credit website take everything I
want has all the information about it so
I don't have to worry about reading it
quite yet but when I get there with a
day before or the dinner before I can
just open up my my Android pull up
Evernote read all about it figure out
where we're going to go that day so I
find that super helpful for organizing
all of my personal and business stuff I
have different notebooks for it I find
really helpful to categorize to expand
and subtract this little arrow here and
I can just minimize
that and then it's back to its main
category and one thing that I just
recently found really helpful is getting
offline access so one of the benefits of
using Evernote is that you can have
access to your notes when you're offline
as well as your online the default is
that it's going to be online so you can
only get access to your notes if you are
actually online one thing that helped
Rison I just came back from New York I
did a radio show there and had some
business deals that I had to get done
there so I made a note here so I'm in a
new notebook called 2013 New York and if
you can read it says private and offline
and so that means all of these notes in
here I can get access to offline so for
example I have my radio show this is
information that I want the part of my
script what I was going to talk about I
had to get directions to the radio show
so staying at the no vote on Times
Square I had to get to 291 Central Park
West and I can it's not scrolling down
let's try that again
radio directions there we go and that's
how to actually get there so I could
just pull this up on my phone get on the
subway I ended up walking it was pretty
good walk but basic I have all the
access to information I need I wanted to
go to Uniqlo one of my favorite stores
to shop at they don't have it here in
Toronto there's two locations in New
York so here they are I could figure out
where I am just pull up my map and I
could walk to the closest location so
all the stuff that I had to do I had my
flight ticket here affluent on Porter my
boarding pass was here easy to get
access my membership card was here so I
can scan it in and get my points it's
all put in this one folder called New
York 2013 and to make sure that you have
access to it at all times the trick to
do this and this was frustrating
actually figure this out on the plane
while I was on the tarmac in Toronto you
click on this little arrow here and that
little arrow when you click on it little
finicky you have this option at the top
that says offline sync so this is
automatically now for offline sync and
this is so important because if you
don't have internet connection you know
when I went to New York I didn't have a
data program if I did I'd be roaming and
have to pay a lot of money so they
only way to get access is if you go to a
Wi-Fi hotspot which is not always
available so you want to have your notes
available so you want to make sure that
you have offline sync on so example for
my Europe trip coming up that's private
but it's not listed as offline yet so I
means when I get there to get access to
my notes I'd have to have to connect to
the internet which will be expensive in
a big pain so I want to make sure that
that's available to me offline I'll
click on that arrow enable offline sync
and now it's going to sync it so that I
can have access regardless of it on the
internet or not so that's a little bit
of a quick hit on how I use my Evernote
on my Android device if you guys have
questions I'd love to answer them for
you from leave it in the comment section
below and if you liked this video please
give it a thumbs up it helps you know
I'm on the right track and I'll do a lot
more of these for you thank you and I
will see you on the next episode
you
you